Almost all cross-testing to kill or pacify
SCP – 682 had failed miserably.
If you haven’t seen it, go watch our video
on the legendary Hard To Kill Reptile, to
see just how powerful and terrifying this
creature is.
It faced the Gate Guardian, an SCP with a
flaming sword hotter than the sun – capable
of tearing your atoms to shreds – and came
out fine.
In its face-off with the horrifying SCP – 096,
also known as the Shy Guy, it broke the Shy
Guy’s mind and reduced it to gibbering despair.
Even SCPs with supposedly unlimited powers
simply refused to engage the beast in combat.
So, when it was proposed that they test 682
with SCP – 999, a creature known among Foundation
staff as “The Tickle Monster,” the idea
was considered laughable.
682 had been burned, suffocated, cut up, incinerated,
and growled in the faces of Gods.
How could this so-called Tickle Monster ever
hope to survive an encounter, let alone win
a fight?
Some even believed that this was the last
we’d see of SCP – 999.
But what makes this story truly remarkable
is that that isn’t how this played out.
As you’ll soon discover, 0SCP – 999 is
an amazing and unique SCP in and of itself,
but its secret origins and its interactions
with some other prominent figures in the SCP
universe are what make this humble, slimy
creature beyond extraordinary.
Prepare yourself for the heartwarming – yes,
you heard that right - the heartwarming story
of SCP – 999.
Several highly-trained agents on 682 detail
placed 999 into the immortal lizard’s cell.
Compared to the giant, reptilian sitting across
from it, 999 wasn’t much to look at – it’s
a large, orange, amorphous blob of anomalous
slime.
Weighing in at around 120 pounds, SCP - 999
was nothing compared to the monstrosity it
was supposed to face.
While its weight has, in the past, caused
minor injuries to some of its human handlers,
it has never caused serious or long-lasting
damage of any kind to a living thing.
Even its diet consists only of candy and sweets,
with a particular preference for M&Ms and
Necco wafers.
It consumes these treats through the cell
membrane of its slimy body, much like an amoeba.
This extremely stretchy membrane means the
creature is highly malleable, including the
ability to stretch and flatten itself out
to a mere two centimeters thick.
At rest, the creature takes a dome-like shape
around two meters wide and one meter in height.
The closest things the creature has to limbs
are prehensile pseudopods, those are the arm-like
projections normally seen on single celled
organisms, of which it has at least three.
The more you hear about this utterly harmless
creature, the more that matching it up with
the pure embodiment of absolute hatred known
as SCP – 682 feels downright cruel.
In absolute contrast to the misanthropic attitudes
of the reptile, 999 loves humans.
It has a playful, dog-like attitude.
Much like an over-excited puppy, when approached,
999 will react with extreme joy and slither
towards the nearest person in order to interact.
It will leap onto them, using two of its three
prehensile pseudopods to hug the person, while
the third nuzzles the person’s face – emitting
high-pitched cooing and gurgling noises throughout.
The creature is apparently pleasant in every
conceivable fashion, as even its odor has
been reported to smell just like the favourite
scent of whoever is smelling it.
Examples have included chocolate, fresh laundry,
bacon, roses, and Play-Doh.
It's almost impossible to oversell just how
beloved and benevolent this strange creature
is.
It’s one of the rare sapient SCPs to earn
the “Safe” class, and it’s allowed to
roam freely around its facility at all times,
apart from a one hour bedtime period between
8 and 9 PM.
In the rare instances that 999 has caused
harm to a worker at the facility, it immediately
began to back away and contract its body while
whimpering in a kind of dog-like apology.
The closest the Foundation had ever come to
having a real incident with the creature was
the time someone accidentally fed it a can
of caffeinated cola, causing it to become
hyper for an hour before becoming visibly
queasy.
You’ll be relieved to know that it’s since
made a full recovery.
But what would happen when this whimsical
creature is forced to go toe-to-toe with the
Foundation’s most ill-tempered monster?
The employees observing the test watched in
suspense as 999 began to enthusiastically
slither towards 682.
It’s no surprise that after being tortured
and almost killed hundreds of times during
testing, 682 had grown jaded to the cross-tests
it was regularly subjected to.
When it saw this strange, orange blob squelching
across the ground towards it, it sighed and
groaned, expecting the worst.
“What is that?”
the creature asked of its gelatinous guest.
SCP – 999 began jumping up and down in front
of 682 like an excited puppy, creating a high-pitched
squealing noise.
Just as it regarded all living things, 682
thought the creature bouncing around before
it was disgusting and hardly worth the effort
to destroy.
Was the Foundation even trying anymore?
With a single vicious stomp, 682 flattened
the friendly creature beneath one of its feet.
Observers were prepared to charge in and liberate
999 from under 682’s claws, but then something
truly unexpected happened.
The expression on 682’s acid-eaten face
began to slowly change.
It was beginning... to smile.
Observers recorded a noise that they thought
could have been a chuckle, as the creature
growled and said, “Hmmm?
What is this…I feel… good…”
While the observers looked on, stunned at
what was happening, 999 began to slither and
crawl up from between 682’s toes.
It reformed on its scaly leg and slithered
up along its side until it reached the neck.
There, it began to nuzzle like it had never
nuzzled before.
The results spoke for themselves.
682 was grinning and chuckling, repeating
a phrase that the Foundation never would have
even imagined coming from 682: “Feel…
so… happy.
Happy…happy… happy…”
Just when you thought SCP – 999 couldn’t
possibly be more adorable, you learn about
its greatest power: Bringing joy.
Anyone and anything that comes into contact
with the creature, even in passing, will experience
a kind of mild euphoria.
As one’s contact with the creature is prolonged,
this overwhelming sense of joy increases,
and continues long after you’re separated
from it.
Prolonged contact has completely cured depression,
anxiety, and PTSD, along with a number of
other conditions, including rage and antisocial
personality disorders.
Serial killers practically become saints after
coming into prolonged contact with 999, and
in that moment, 682 was no exception.
And there truly does appear to be no exceptions.
While “causing happiness and joy” isn’t
a dangerous weapon, when it comes to SCP – 999,
it is an extremely powerful one.
And what’s more, SCP – 999 also appears
to have an innate sense for those who need
its help most – with a particular affection
for the hurt and the unhappy.
The creature appears to be a true altruist
on a fundamental level, even risking its own
safety to help humans during dangerous containment
breaches.
In one dramatic instance, 999 leaped into
the air to block a bullet from making contact
with a member of staff.
As a result, the creature is pretty much universally
loved by all members of Foundation staff.
It’s the one SCP who never made trouble
for anyone.
Back in SCP – 682’s containment cell,
the beast was still smiling and laughing as
999 rubbed against its neck.
It was an event so strange, so unprecedented
that the observers in attendance felt like
they were hallucinating.
For a few minutes, the monster kept dreamily
repeating the word “happy” but then, suddenly,
the creature began to enter a fit of uncontrollable,
booming laughter.
It rolled onto its back, slamming its huge
tail against the door.
It’d just fallen victim to one of 999’s
favorite pastimes: Tickle Fights, hence how
it earned its Tickle Monster nickname among
staff.
The tickle fight continued until 682 appeared
to tire and fall asleep, with a smile still
on its face.
After fifteen minutes of inactivity, two D-Class
personnel were commanded to enter and retrieve
SCP – 999 from the containment cell.
They did so successfully, but as soon as 999
was removed, 682 roused from its slumber and
released a powerful psychic attack from its
entire body while laughing maniacally.
It rendered all personnel within a certain
distance incapacitated as they collapsed in
fits of laughter, allowing 682 to escape and
go on a violent rampage.
However, in spite of this, 999 showed no fear,
and helped save some of the bystanders as
security officers subdued and recaptured 682.
And even after all this, 999 showed no hard
feelings towards 682, and indicated a desire
to play again.
It’s a creature whose capacity for love
is so limitless that it’s practically immune
to fear.
Which is all well and good, because the true
enemy that 999 is destined to face is infinitely
more powerful and terrifying than 682 could
ever hope to be.
What is this monster, and why should 999 have
to face it someday?
The answers to these questions all lie in
the true origins of SCP – 999, available
only to those with level 5 clearance and beyond.
It’s a perfect example of how something
good can come from the darkest places…
There would be no SCP – 999 without SCP
– 231 – 7.
SCP – 231 was a collection of seven girls,
all impregnated by horrific nightmares in
a ritual performed by a cult known as the
Children of the Scarlet King.
Each of these girls, over the years that followed,
gave birth to some of the most horrific monsters
imaginable – one of which, according to
some, was SCP – 682.
These beings were manifested by the Scarlet
King, a powerful interdimensional nightmare
God, believed to be behind a great deal of
the darkness and horror present within our
and many other dimensions.
Foundation higher-ups have declared the Scarlet
King to be the greatest existing threat to
the Multiverse at large, and SCP – 231 was
his latest direct interaction with our universe.
The only surviving member of SCP – 231,
SCP – 231 – 7, gave birth in secret.
But she didn’t give birth to a monster – she
gave birth to SCP – 999, a being of pure
goodness.
That’s right: The nicest, kindest, cuddliest
SCP of all is the direct descendent of a being
that’s essentially the Dark God of all evil.
Feel free to take a moment to absorb that.
The creature even healed the girl who birthed
it, and allowed her to return to normal life
with her family once more.
From its first moments, SCP - 999 was making
positive changes to the world around it.
And according to ancient texts from a Scarlet
King-aligned culture known as the Daevas,
SCP – 999 is still very much in its infancy,
yet it already has the power to pacify its
monstrous siblings like the aforementioned
682.
It’s believed, according to some prophecies
and Foundation theories, that the power of
SCP – 999 will grow exponentially as it
matures.
Why does this matter?
Well, it’s believed by some that one day
999 will grow powerful enough to overthrow
not only its own monstrous siblings, but the
thought-to-be-unstoppable Scarlet King himself.
Not through violence or hate, but through
the pure force of happiness and love burning
out the darkness and purifying the corrupted.
While the humble SCP – 999 rarely outshines
its frightening competitors, to those truly
in the know, 999 is one of the most powerful
and valuable SCPs in existence, and may be
the greatest asset in the Foundation’s arsenal
for the war against dangerous anomalous activity.
After all, what could strike more fear into
their hearts than the knowledge that it might
be love rather than firepower that finally
dethrones the Scarlet King?
And for the knowledge that it may one day
save everything we know from a fate so much
worse than death with nothing but affection
for everyone and everything, it’s worth
offering thanks to the little orange blob,
or at least an extra pack of M&Ms before bedtime.